what's up wisecrack
jared here today we're talking about a
colossal series with amazing fight
scenes
a [ __ ] ton of crying cowards and
gargantuan steamy ken dolls
attack on titan many anime properties
explore death
but very few ruminate on the visceral
reality of it
quite like attack on titan in a way
titans are the physical personification
of death
walking reminders of human mortality a
sort of existential confrontation with
the inevitability of demise
it's pretty horrifying however the
darkest element of the series
isn't the eerily introspective
confrontations with death
or the fact that titans have no genitals
it's the construction of the society
behind the walls itself
the show is set in an anachronistic
quasi-germanic society full of german
architecture
german war cries
and characters with german names my name
is thomas wagner i'm from the cross
district but the similarities to german
history don't stop
there upon closer inspection the
political ideology of this society
lines up with the beliefs of one of the
most notorious nazi philosophers
carl schmidt now just to be clear
schmidt is a real piece of [ __ ]
dude was a card-carrying nazi
unrepentant to the end
we are in no way saying that his ideas
are good nor is attack on titan saying
they're good we are saying that the show
can be understood as an exploration of
his ideas
what makes attack on titan so dark is
that it presents us with a society
faced with a horrific enemy that
maintains stability while reflecting
nazi ideology is attack on titan one of
the most provocative shows out there
not because of the balls to the wall
violence but because it dares to ask
is it possible that in this dystopian
society a controversial philosophy may
be the only thing keeping the fabric of
society from collapsing
welcome to this wisecrack edition on
attack on titan spoiler alert
and oh yeah we're only covering the tv
show not the manga they're going to be
different anyway
you are officially on my [ __ ] list also
we had to use dubs so we don't have
subtitles all over the video
so please don't freak out i love you
central to schmidt's philosophy and
attack on titan's civilization
is the concept of what he calls the
political there are three concepts that
situate the political
and create a stable society conflict and
inequality
clear distinction between friends and
enemies and sovereignty
the first thing that schmidt highlights
is that conflict division and inequality
among human beings
is inevitable central to this is an
understanding that humanity in its most
basic nature is
savage and hellish people are
essentially shitty and life isn't fair
this world hasn't become hell it's been
hell
strength preys on weakness it's a very
straightforward arrangement actually
mikasa armin and aaron all make
arguments about the way the world is
that are completely in line with this
thinking
when young mikasa is kidnapped it is the
image of a mantis eating a moth
and her father with a duck he hunted
that kick-starts the killing spree that
saves her and aaron
it's a constant theme that the show
returns to it's a dog-eat-dog world
and you have to fight to survive the
world's a cool place
if you want to live you have to fight
this constant war
against all is in line with philosopher
thomas hobbes understanding of
humanity's most basic nature
we're all monsters at heart and social
structures are the only thing that can
keep us at bay
schmidt takes things a step further it
isn't just that people are terrible
rather hostility is unavoidable for
schmidt
inequality is sort of inevitable people
will always be
smarter fitter more attractive and it's
not the job of politics to fix that
if society is to function properly
according to schmidt
it doesn't make sense to attempt to
eliminate antagonism or inequality
because they will always exist instead a
strong
sovereign ought to be concerned with
maintaining order and control of the
population
focusing on social issues like
inequality misses the point for him
in attack on titan we see this firsthand
classes are separated by literal walls
each wall section is its own caste
system the people in walmaria are not as
safe as the people inside wall rose and
cena while people are being eaten
in tross people in the inner cities are
chilling in castles playing chess and
[ __ ]
the scouts venture past the walls and
risk their lives
while the mps in the inner walls barely
know how to use their omnidirectional
mobility gear they sort of just get
drunk all day
hey sorry about that back to business
most media narratives would see
severe inequality as something to be
repaired but in attack on titan
we haven't seen much evidence of that at
least yet
trying to alleviate things like
inequality for schmidt is a distraction
from what's really important for the
political
nationalism and survival and this is
where the parallels between the series
and schmidt
get pretty creepy nowhere is this focus
on the nationalistic duty of the warrior
class more apparent than in the theme
song for the first half of season 1
which looks and sounds like triumph of
the will level nationalistic propaganda
the lyrics of the song are about
fighting past defeat trampling over
corpses
having the will of starving wolves and
piercing scarlet holes in twilight with
bows and arrows over scenes of the
soaring military
and crazy battle scenes it may as well
have been a post-world war one rallying
cry for the defeated german people
which gets us to the second element of
the political a clear distinction
between
friend and enemy the idea is good
governments need an
enemy to struggle against without
completely dominating them
the titans provide a sort of check
against total conquest beyond the wall
without a clear enemy human nature
drives a war
against all an unending civil war full
of war crimes dehumanization
and the eradication of your own people
becomes an inevitability
the existence of a clear enemy impedes
the quest for constant war and
infighting
both ervin and pixus are concerned with
this friend enemy distinction
titans aren't our only foe who do you
think the real enemy is here
on the wall with aaron pixus makes this
very comment about the necessity of
titans as the enemy
before the titans held sway mankind
consisted of scores of different races
different creeds
all scratching and biting at each other
for blood humanity required an enemy
greater than itself just to survive
both pixas and irvin smith worry that
the titans aren't the actual enemy that
they are not the real threat
that the real threat is humanity itself
the titans merely keep people in line
they give everyone a common goal
if we're wiped off the face of the earth
the culprits will not have been the
titans
we'll have done it to ourselves if the
line isn't drawn now it won't be drawn
at all
now the purpose of the titans is not yet
revealed in the show
we know that there's a face in the wall
and that there are abnormal titans that
are controlled by people
it could be the case that they're merely
tools of the elite to lower the
population
it was little more than a purge a thinly
disguised exercise in population control
they could be trying to break people out
of their cages or they could just be
evil
if annie is in fact working for
government officials to create
emergencies and lower population if the
rogue titans are in fact part of an
inside conspiracy
then what we have is a government
fabricated enemy
a threat that is a schmidty and wet
dream an intelligent
strong naked enemy worthy of battle that
will keep humanity from fighting each
other
also incidentally if this were the case
it would be a great criticism of
schmidt's politics
in a way the titans could be read as an
allegory for the perfect scapegoat as
the source of
all fears that mobilizes a population
and gives the people in control
their very power even in the show's
theme of freedom
it reflects schmidt's friend enemy
distinction the scout's badge is the
wings of freedom
aaron and armin are constantly crying
about a life beyond the walls
and humanity is likened to penned in
cattle home
was a pen humanity cattle
more than that freedom and community for
schmidt is defined as denying cowardice
in the face of impending death
risked it all for even a glimmer of real
freedom
doesn't matter what's waiting outside
the gate or what comes in fights
joining the scouts is a sort of
liberation from the fear of living
inside the wall waiting to die
man that'd be amazing shut up marco
you just want a nice cushy job in the
interior playing glorified century
that's not true
the desire to join the scouts together
cements aaron's class as a community
but not just any community a political
community that gives life
a purpose the battlefield i don't want
the easy life
i train to fight titans are you insane
for schmidt a political community is
defined by the ability to kill your
enemies for the sake of your friends
or dying at the hands of your enemies
for the sake of your friends
the scouts that risk their lives are
like the troops in the alfred tennyson
poem
the charge of the light brigade yeah
attack on titan characters quote
shakespeare
and tennyson ask not the reason why ask
what to do and die
having him quote tennyson is
particularly prescient the charge of the
life brigade is an exemplar war poem
about dying with your comrades in battle
especially given how many scouts die
fighting annie this sense of camaraderie
and political community is what binds
together the remnants of humanity
rather than letting them tear themselves
apart however the friend enemy
distinction gets a little fuzzier as the
show progresses
aaron and annie being titans erodes the
clear line between a foreign enemy
and a domestic friend it's why the
partial transformation scene
when aaron saves mikasa and armin from
cannon fire is
essential aaron jaeger what exactly are
you
human or titan it shows what happens
when there isn't a clear division
between human and titan
the line between who needs to be
protected and from what
blurs and it makes the task of securing
the population
near impossible the final element of
schmidt's the political is the power of
the sovereign itself
sovereign entities have the ability to
declare states of emergency that justify
sacrificing populations for the greater
good
like sending a battalion to reclaim
walmaria we supported the
state-sponsored myth because the deaths
of our fellow human beings allowed us to
survive
pure and simple the citizens of war
maria sustained themselves on the
wholesale slaughter of the refugees
who'd flown to us for help
the ability to declare this kind of
state of emergency is crucial for the
long-term stability of most
societies you don't want political
bickering getting in the way of fighting
the giant monster that's about to murder
you all
the sovereign can also make exceptions
in the law like
special citizen status for people to
live inside walt cena
in attack on titan we don't have a very
good explanation for how the political
works outside of the military it appears
that the current leadership structure is
based on martial law and military rule
sure we know that premier darius zachary
is in charge of the military tribunal
that has the power to execute aaron
and we know that the wall cultists have
grown in power since the attack on
shiganshina these lunatics all worship
the walls as if they're some kind of
gods
it creeps me out but the actual
structure outside of military control
hasn't been revealed yet we do know that
the leaders send
millions to their death to ensure the
safety of the rest of the people inside
the walls
pixis explains that the retaking of
walmaria was little more than a thinly
disguised purge to ease the stress from
the massive influx of refugees
it was a decision to kill off part of
the population
for the greater good this is the
threshold of our extinction soldiers
if my actions ensure mankind's survival
history may call me butcher all at once
as twisted as this sounds for schmidt
the sovereign must maintain this ability
to do even the most horrendous of things
if order is to be maintained so
wisecrack with this in mind i invite you
to ponder this
what would happen if all the titans
suddenly disappeared
would society devolve into anarchy would
there be a civil war
inside the walls that would be even more
brutal than the occasional titan attack
or would it be an opportunity for
liberation and greater peace
for schmidt eradicating your enemy isn't
an option because there's
always a drive for warfare another enemy
to be found
eliminate one enemy and another one pops
up until there are no people left to
kill
but your own population of course we
should be wary of a guy who warned about
unending war
while being a principal theorist for the
nazi party there's still a pretty robust
debate in academia about the
redeemability and use of schmidt's work
for understanding international conflict
people still invoke schmidt when
discussing executive power
the pitfalls of our current system and
even the war on terror
attack on titan could go in so many
directions it could reverse course and
become a scathing criticism of
schmidt-style politics
or it could simply complicate them we'll
just have to wait for season 2 to find
out
you know there was so much to cover in
the show and we had a great time doing
it so make sure to let us know what you
think about the video in the comments
below